Here's the beauty of
the Span sync framework.
You can analyze the work and the Span of
algorithms in almost exactly the same
way that you do for
sequential algorithms.
So almost everything you learned in
Algorithms 101 you get to reuse here.
Hooray!
Let me illustrate this by example.
Here's pseudocode for doing a sequential
reduction using divide and conquer.
If this were CS algorithms 101 and
we were analyzing this running time,
we'd start by writing down a recurrence
relation and then solving the relation.
So in this algorithm we divide the work
into two pieces and do recursive calls.
And that translates into
a recurrence that looks like this,
where we solve two sub-problems,
each one of half the size.
And you can solve this recurrence
in any number of ways.
For example,
you can use the master theorem.
What you'll find is that
the time is linear in N.
If you don't remember what
the master theorem is,
we'll put a link in
the instructor's notes.
Okay, so
what about the parallel version?
Remember, you want to analyze work and
span.
Now let's assume that each spawn and
sync is a constant time operation.
It turns out, this is not
a bad assumption in practice.
Now recall that analyzing the work
is just counting total operations.
Therefore, if spawn and sync
are essentially constant time, then for
the analysis,
we can effectively ignore the spawns and
syncs and
just do the usual sequential analysis.
So the recurrence for
work looks just like the recurrence for
sequential execution time and
we'll get linear work.
Hey, that's pretty neat.
It means algorithm analysis with respect
to work is no harder than it was for
sequential algorithms.
Okay, what about span?
Span is a little different.
Let me explain this
by a simpler example.
Now remember that a spawn creates a
branch and a dag which yields two paths.
The critical path will be the longer
of these two paths Therefore if
I knew the length of the path going
through A and the length of the path
going through B, then the critical path
would just be the longer of those two.
Mathematically, we say
the span is the maximum
of the span going through A versus
the span going through B.
Now for our divide and
conquer reduction,
the span only depends
on the problem size N.
And our cursive call solve
problems of roughly equal size.
Therefore when we write down
the recurrence for span,
we'll get something
that looks like this.
So the recurrence in this case is
just a constant plus the span of n/2,
and I'll let you solve this one.